let's do this let's jump to the next
segment where we can talk about the
ramifications of
social justice stuff and this this will
be probably a little bit more outside
your wheelhouse but i'm sure you'll
still be able to make fun of them ryan
so over in virginia the new law
banning police from pulling over
virginia drivers solely for certain car
safety violations
officers can also not stop people if
they smell marijuana
so in virginia they passed new
legislations taking effect monday
so i believe i believe it what it's all
it's already taken effect yeah i think
so
we'll make it harder for authorities in
virginia to pull over drivers
several minor infractions while still
illegal can no longer be the primary
reason police stop you while you're
driving
these include certain defective
equipment objects dangling from your
rear view mirror loud exhaust
tinted windows and smelling marijuana to
name a few an expired inspection or
registration sticker can only get you
pulled over however
it has to be at least four months late
the legislation lists more changes
here maybe we can pull these up and see
what they see what they are going on
social
justice advocates say this is a win i
think it's a first step it's a huge
first step said brad haywood
founder and executive director of
justice forward virginia haywood said
these violations have long been used to
stop people from drug investigations
and disproportionately target people of
color well
i think it's it's it's i'm not going to
read this whole law i don't know there's
a whole bunch of crazy stuff in it
i do think it's kind of absurd that cops
can't pull people over now because
the original proposal was it was like
black lives matter protesters were
saying they just pull over people of
color and they use it as excuses
i think cops use things as excuses i've
had cops pull me over
i had a cop pulled me over once and as
soon as like i roll the window down
i put my you know my keys and wallet on
top of the dash i put my hands on the
steering wheel i turn the radio off he
walks up
and the first the cop does is go excuse
me oh whoa
he's i smell marijuana and i'm like
i'm sorry yeah that's my cologne i'm
like i'm
no i i i i just got off work i was
wearing my work jumpsuit from o'hare
and i worked a double shift my car was
full of taco bell wrappers which is
maybe why he thought he could get away
with accusing me of smoking pot plus
magnet you and oh totally the whole no
you don't understand when i mean full i
mean like
the ground and the chair was a mound of
taco bell right there was a moving trash
you were that guy yeah i was like 19. no
but he pulled me over and he
and he was like i smell pot and i was
like i don't smoke and he's like out of
the car
i got coughed they searched my vehicle
and tried planting pot in my car yeah no
joke
so i see stuff like this and i'm like i
understand but
it's also kind of crazy that someone
could literally be smoking pot and the
cop can't pull them over well if they
see it i think they still can
right i guess yeah just if they smell
marijuana but i mean come on if like
i i grew up i grew up in chicago people
smoked pot all the time and they what
they call it clambake
or hot boxing boxing a little bit of
both it depends on where you're from in
the country
clambake or hotboxing because when they
close all the windows and then just the
whole thing gets fogged up yes
and i'm like okay so the cop can't see
anything it's just smoke right
so when they open he says i saw smoke
like what kind of smoke was it
well they can probably bust you if
you're there and they walk up to the
window now they just can't stop you
so if but when is a cop gonna smell it
driving as you drive by that's probably
not very common
it can happen bro you've never driven
past a car
those guys are going at it dude dude you
can see people driving in the smoke
coming out of there
definitely see it yeah yeah no no but
the bigger picture here is
are we getting to the point where the
sensitivities over the social justice
stuff are getting the point where like a
cop
can't pull someone over for literally
breaking the law it's
obviously when you go to the extremes at
any of these things i always used to say
like in comedy
because essentially there's like a war
on noticing things
you know like because it's a you know
good point a big thing that you don't
talk about is like oh you know women
kind of do this more a guy's going to do
this more and you go
oh it's interesting that black guys kind
of do this or like you know whatever it
is like that's
base level but noticing things that and
then kind of
that's funny right pattern discernment
yeah literal yeah literally
noticing patterns in your brain right
you're admitting to being a bigot yeah
exactly right so
yeah there's there's a it's a war on
noticing things where you go there
but it's it's so manufactured and it's
so fake and so this is what happens when
it gets these things get taken to their
extreme
but i agree with you that the cops do do
all that stuff put it this way i used to
have really long hair
like this guy and i sh i i cut my hair
and i've never been pulled over since i
cut my hair and when i had long hair
like him
honey dude when i had long hair like him
twice at the airport i was searched my
entire
bag searched i was pulled over for no
reason lots of different times
and since i've cut my hair 10 years ago
never happened again so
you know they're one of course they do
and i've had
cops do all sorts of crazy stuff but
this is crazy let me read this there's a
quote why should they be allowed to
investigate people based on hunches when
they have no evidence
why don't we expect them to actually get
probable cause for drug position
or gun position before they pull a call
car over hayward said
i read that and i'm like that's kind of
like oxymoronic a hunch that's what
probable cause is like a reasonable
you know i like you have a reasonable
probable cause is that
you have a reasonable suspicion that
someone is doing something to be a hunch
right sounds like a hunch yeah you know
it's one of those things like a
reasonable doubt
yeah you go most people for a lot of the
problems we go
do you think it's bad that you know
there's these bad cops pulling people
over and you go
yeah and i think most people go that's a
problem you go what's the solution they
go cops can't pull anyone else over and
you go oh
that's not what it is that's totally
reasonable i wasn't saying that and
you're like road pops for the boys yeah
crack a pack of mojos because the boys
are
rocking out on the way to the cottage i
i think you know i would we need a
visual representation of this idea
where it's like exactly what you said
you know it's kind of it's kind of bad
that like
what a statistic like you know one in a
certain number of cops will do something
defund all police abolish all the cops
you know what i mean it's always the
logical
extreme of okay we don't want this and i
i think
so many things like with the censorship
and everything it's the same problem you
go
most people if me and you are having a
conversation they go that was kind of
mean what that guy did you know and we
go yeah that was
you know what was that guy doing at this
party calling that girl this or whatever
right
right and then yeah and then and then
he's like i agree and then the next day
you found out he's like
petitioning for laws that it's illegal
to be mean at the party and you go well
that's not
right you know people want to legislate
their what they consider
their morality you know what i mean it's
like people want the government to be
legislating their moral principles
and i think that's kind of we don't all
have the same moral principles
right right so this actually happened
lansing this is uh i'm assuming this is
michigan right yeah
they they pass something similar say new
guidelines lansing police won't
won't stop drivers solely for minor
infractions
they say the new guidelines are
consistent with the department's goal of
protecting citizens rights while
eliminating any aspect in further
otherwise of bias-based traffic policing
practices
so so let me get this straight you've
got this happening in michigan you got
it in virginia
they're saying cops can't pull you over
if your license plate is expired
all right that's that's that's kind of a
problem i mean you register your car for
a reason you're paying taxes you're
contributing
so the issue i have here well i wonder
if the libertarians are all cheering
there's always good i am deep down i am
for sure but there's also the other
element of
making you know the most aggressive laws
to force you into that position
where you go well i don't know like
you're all of a sudden pro cop yeah and
then they go look at this guy's like
blue lives matter dude and they kind of
it's like they pick these extreme
positions that everyone's like
i mean that's a little crazy and you're
like what you know they do
it's like with all the issues the issue
now is basically
all they're really saying is you don't
have to get your license plate renewed
for four months for four months so
that's actually kind of fine i guess you
get a four-month buffer then what's the
point of putting the sticker on your
plate
why bother going and getting a renewal
if you know you can't get in trouble for
it you can't get pulled over before it
could be like a covid like
we're not gonna make just like a little
buffer that in case people can't afford
to get the lessons right
that the point is cops are supposed to
just give you a warning
so well not supposed to but i think i
think they should be supposed to
so when when my plate expired on my on
my car when i was like 19 the one for
the taco bell rappers
it was a different time yeah i got
pulled over clam magnet
yeah yeah totally dude you have no idea
when those ladies saw the taco bell they
were like
oh is that taco bell no no they were
like i'm about to unwrap my tacos the
amount of rappers in your car must be
clearly ten thousand dollars worth of
tacos
when i got pulled over the cop walked up
to the car and he said
uh your plates are expired and i was
like oh
really i was like i don't know man i'm
like i was like i just
had just got the car i have no idea how
this works anyway no problem just go get
it fixed dude everything's burritos
today i can't deal with this right now
i was like officer oh i ate too much
taco bell it's coming
no no he was just he just walked up and
he was like get it updated
and i was like yeah all right thanks man
and then i got pulled over again like a
week later
and the same thing happened cop walked
up and he goes you know license
insurance and he goes your
your license plates expired and i said
straight up i was like ah yeah man i
just had a warning from a cop
and you know he told me to get
registered so i went to the thing i got
it
filled out i guess it's coming soon
anyway okay have a nice day i suppose
that's the kind of story
where you hear these progressive
leftists being like when i got pulled
over for an expired plate they gave me a
warning or
when i was going 120 in a 35 school zone
they gave me a slap on their
speeding is different yeah they're like
i killed a guy and no one even knows yet
when a black guy does it
you go what you killed who knows like if
if you get pulled over
for speeding and your license is expired
then you're in trouble
in my opinion yeah if your license
plate's expired but if you just
are the speeding is dangerous speeding
can kill people that's
i think you should always the cops
should be very diligent about pulling
over people for speeding
so i think like i don't know you made
the point really well it's you say hey
is it kind of bad that sometimes cops
pull people over for ps reasons
you're right no cops should be able to
pull anyone over that's like a really
extreme crazy thing
but the issue i have a lot of these
stories from a scientific perspective
is when like lived experience is not
science
you know did you were you following the
smith college thing that happened
recently
will smith went to college yeah will
smith
they're rebooting back to school with
rodney dangerfield it's with this time
no no so there's a school where there
was this black woman and she was in an
unauthorized area of the university
eating
so the janitor was told if anybody goes
in there just call the security
security got called they went there and
they asked her the cop was just like you
know what's going on and she was like
i'm eating and she's like shaking and
filming him
and he was like okay you know sorry to
bother you just you know we're supposed
to have anybody in here but you it's
fine if you're here
and then she claimed it was this big
like super racist moment
yeah so the new york times wrote an
article saying it was a moment when her
lived personal truth was at clash with
the facts
the new york times actually wrote that
so the problem i have is
how do we know you know if like
someone's
when someone says i get pulled over for
no reason it's like the difficult
thing is there's no control right we
can't send one card on a rope the same
cop
no and then with like with like an asian
driver and then a black driver and a
white driver and then see which one gets
pulled over and there's multiple factors
like some girls think that i'm like you
know
talking like an asian girl or whatever
and she's like oh you're being mean to
me because i'm asian and i'm actually
just being mean to her because she's a
woman
right exactly you never really know
right you're just trying to find ways to
be offensive and no matter what point
you make
you're like let me offend as many people
as possible on this show
uh i but you have to understand when i
did uh
say that i meant one max and nixon
if the x is pronounced with y i think
it's pronounced xxx and oh my gosh
so they
they say it's pronounced uh the x is uh
pronounced
you're supposed to it's the two arms and
uh there's a socket under
that's the under context that's the
subtext they don't want you to know that
well apparently the word that's the x
factor
the word defensive to everybody sector
so everybody's offended by it
but no you can't like if you're
everyone's had
those experiences and you go and it kind
of goes to why i mean
i was saying the other day that like
there's a lot of people that
they're fox news when it's uh agrees
with them and they're they're cnn when
it doesn't like for example if you say
someone will go
okay that different racial groups have
different crime war right and they'll be
like obviously that's because of the
system and you go okay well then why do
guys
go to jail less than women and they go
well that's because women are less
violent and you go
right you legitimately switch between me
and fox news and cnn based on whether
it's the
group that you care about because guys
are more violent yeah well exactly right
i mean
and you go obviously a lot of these
things are a mix of they're all
multi-variable things
but nuance is difficult and takes a lot
of energy and oh it's not very
good for activism it's not allowed yeah
it's like they're there's
like legit scientific conversations are
very very hard to have on youtube
because they'll try and get you banned
for talking about
actual scientific studies they'll argue
the studies themselves were fake or
bigoted or paid off and it's like
so which one which paid off study do you
pick i guess like yeah it's all
political i kind of have that
that same mentality sometimes when it's
like oh you can't talk about this
because you're a man or whatever
whatever it is
and i go all right give me a list of
things that i'm not allowed to talk
about and let's avoid those subjects
cause i'm not about to hear you like
just listen to you speak and be like
zip it up that's basically what they do
yeah you go oh you're not allowed to
talk on this one's like i guess let's
move on then
because that doesn't sound very
interesting to me thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you